foreign
30 years ago the Oslo Accords were
signed between Israel and the Palestine
Liberation Organization the agreements
were seen as a major turning point in
the conflict because it was the first
time that Israel and the PLO formally
recognized one another this image became
iconic on the 13th of September
1993. PLO chairman yasa Arafat and
Israel's then prime minister Chuck Rabin
shakans on the White House law and
overseen by the U.S President Bill
Clinton the Oslo Accords were a series
of agreements signed between 1993 and
1999 with a goal that aimed to see
Israel withdraw from the territories it
occupied during June 1967's War
including the West Bank East Jerusalem
and Gaza and so most Palestinians
believe that the Accords would create an
independent Palestinian state in the
occupied territories alongside Israel
but that never happened over the next 30
Years Israel accelerated his expansion
of legal settlements increased
restrictions on the movement of
Palestinians within the occupied
territories and built a separation wall
as well as imposing a Siege on the Gaza
Strip through its Land Air and sea
blockade three decades on the Oslo
Accords are seen to have only served to
cement Israel's occupation Paul Brennan
reports now from occupied East Jerusalem
yossi Balin was offered a Nobel Peace
Prize for his role in the Oslo Accords
it was he who instigated the secret back
Channel talks which led eventually to
that momentous handshake on the White
House lawn but the 30-year anniversary
brings him no Pride it was not meant for
so many years who who dreamed that this
a Zone and b-zone and season
would be there for so many years it is
crazy
and the fact that it is still there is
its biggest failure the Oslo Accords
were never a conventional peace deal
always just a transitional road map
negotiations over the final status
Arrangements things like borders the
Palestinian State the return of refugees
and most crucially the fate of Jerusalem
itself were all to come later but they
never did and 30 years on with Benjamin
Netanyahu still the dominant force in
Israeli Politics the prospect of those
negotiations resuming looked more
distant than ever I think you can say
that it failed the process failed um is
it on the Palestinians did not separate
they are not coexisting peacefully side
by side as was the goal
um the era of Palestinian terrorism
isn't over the Israeli settlement
Enterprise has expanded in fact we're
more intertwined than was the case there
it seems harder it's a more intractable
conflict
in his near 30-year political career
Benjamin Netanyahu has never wavered
from his support for Israeli settlement
building in the occupied West Bank
Israel's assertion that it has no
partner with which to talk peace is
common parlance and Israel has set about
convincing the Arab Nations that
so-called real politics should take
precedence a normalization with Saudi
Arabia is the prize on The Horizon
apparently the idea of Netanyahu is
first to make a normalization or peace
whatever he calls it with the Arab world
then to
trip the Palestinians from their Arab
support
and then to be able to dictate to the
Palestinians his solution
on the Palestinian side
it's not simple with Hamas and fatah and
whatever but still I believe that Abu
mazan is the partner for peace
for now though the signing of the Oslo
Accords is the story of an incomplete
Journey a project as yet unfinished and
possibilities so far unfulfilled
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem
let's bring it into Ibrahim who's in
Bethlehem overlooking the illegal
Israeli settlement of har hamba and it
is an anniversary but certainly not one
that everybody is celebrating
on the contrary Palestinians would tell
you that in the Oslo Accords there
wasn't an Israeli commitment to stop the
illegal Israeli settlement building this
illegal settlement of har hamar has been
built on the lands of Palestinians it
used to be called jabalabone people
recall coming here playing here having
lands now if you can see it's a huge
building complex there are lots and lots
of Israelis living here this has been
built in the 1991 which is basically two
years before the Oslo Accords have been
signed so if it tells you anything it
tells you how much it expanded it became
bigger and bigger even when Israel has
signed an interim agreement that was
supposed to take Palestinians into
statehood what's happening now as far as
Palestinians are concerned is that these
settlements are preventing any
possibility for having a contiguous
State because these are the lands of
Bethlehem they're close to the lands of
Jerusalem and this settlement kind of
cuts any possibility for a future
contiguous Palestinian States where
people in Bethlehem in Jerusalem and
elsewhere in the West Bank feel
connected to one another the apron for
the update thank you of course we'll be
joining you through the day thank you